labor seems to have resurrected its
pre-1997 twin track approach to
formulating policy firstly shutting down
historically tricky areas for the party
immigration defense bits of Economic
Policy by making sure there is very
little difference between them and the
conservatives and then at the same time
honing in on key issues whether it is a
clear contrast like getting rid of tax
breaks on private schools and when
zakiristama raised this today he made
reference to Rishi sunak's own Elite
Education
Winchester college has a Rowing Club a
Rifle Club an extensive art collection
they charge over 45
000 pounds a year in fees why did he
hand them nearly six million pounds of
taxpayers money this year in what is
leveling up secretary calls egregious
State support now that was a nod to
Michael goves back into this very policy
just five years ago if he thinks the
route to better education in this
country is tax breaks for private
schools in the hope they might hand that
sum that down to Statesville all that's
laughable
trickle-down education is nonsense
some conservatives call Labor's policy
class war and the PM argued it's an
attack on aspiration
because we've recently announced
billions more funding for our schools
we're helping millions of the most
disadvantaged children catch up with
their lost learning we're never he
attacks me about where I went to school
he is attacking the hard-working
aspiration of millions of people in this
country
he's attacking people like my parents Mr
Speaker this is the country that
believes in Opportunity not resentment I
thought it was notable that the PM
didn't make the argument that if the tax
breaks end and private schools closed
then the state and taxpayers will likely
have to Fork out Rishi sunak did however
raise Labor's internal divisions on
strikes and picket lines kistama tried
to exploit to Tory splits on house
building and we witnessed both leaders
calling each other weak
he's too weak to stop dozens of his own
MPS joining the picket lines
every week he gets pushed around and
every week he gets weaker elsewhere the
smps in Blackfoot attacked both the
government and the opposition and that's
an even worse site watching the leader
of the labor party desperately trying to
outbreaks at the prime minister
[Applause]
[Music]
and there was clear frustration from the
PM's own side on immigration the number
of people crossing the channel is a
National Emergency the number of
migrants in hotels is a National
Emergency when will my right honorable
friend government bring forward any
emergency legislation that's needed to
deport those migrants who came across
the channel illegally well five weeks
into this new pmq's pairing Kia St Arma
seems desperate to paint Wishy sunak as
weak he's got a message and he's going
to repeat it the danger for the PM
though is if voters think that barb is
believable it could soon stick